[Music]
so far so good and great to see you
Katie I'm really excited to be here to
learn more about CI CD with GCP ah great
question Katie so what we are doing over
here is we are using Google cloud
platforms tools specifically developer
tools to create a continuous integration
and a continuous delivery pipeline so
the tools which you are seeing over here
specifically target three specific areas
which is storing your source code
creating a build and testing it and then
essentially deploying it to walk us
through those three steps yeah but
before I go over there let me take a
step back and tell you more about the
demo so in the demo what we are doing
over here is we're really creating easy
way for our attendees to understand how
you can set up a CI CD pipeline in a
really easy to do fashion so what you
would see is we would start from writing
code and storing it now we would
obviously not be writing code the write
code we would be actually pressing the
red button thank you very nice though if
writing code was as simple as pushing a
red button obviously I would really like
that so similarly when the code has been
written we would create a build and test
it using our offering which we recently
release at next which is called cloud
build once it has been built we would
deploy it to depending upon which
environment you want whether you want to
deploy it your own friend whether you
want it to deploy it to cloud we support
both so let's walk you through the demo
so the first in the form of screen which
you see on the screen is where you want
to store your source code github and
bitbucket probably you might be familiar
with but Google itself comes with Google
has an offering which is called as cloud
source repositories which is a private
git repo we see our customers using
cloud source repositories for two
specific use
one it comes with built-in integrations
to GCP tools and second specifically
with integrations to scrag tower it
gives you really good debugging
capabilities since Gaucho's repositories
is built-in it has built-in integrations
with stackdriver so for today's demo
purposes let's say our source code is
going to be stored in cloud source
repositories as I said what we do is we
break the read button and then it goes
into writing the code phase as you can
see we are really not writing the code
over here manually what we are doing is
clicking the red button and playing the
slot machine okay so as we do it four
times the core gets written the next
step obviously is creating the build so
we have something called as cloud build
which is C ICD platform which lets you
create both containers as well as non
continuous specific builds okay the
three different shaders for Exploud both
specifically are scalability as you
start ramping up your bills and cause
different team members and different
projects it still gives you fast
feedback in a CI environment the second
is security as we would see in the next
part of the demo it comes with both in
vulnerability scanner and the third part
or the third part of this cloud probe
which differentiates is the flexibility
P so put a biggest cloud of flexibility
is with comes with a Yama file and it
lets you define build steps for
specifically for building the containers
or even non-contingent artifact testing
it and deploying it how is the demo so
far KD
something fails something field and
probably that's because I Rea I wrote
some unit tests and they found some
flaws in my build
ok so the next step obviously is fixing
those flaws and guess what how are you
gonna fix those walls again by pressing
the red button over here of course right
if only life was this easy right
absolutely
so right now you would see in the
background cloudbuilt triggers a build
mm-hmm the build will take 10 to 15
seconds to build
and we can see on the screen the
progress bar once the bill gets created
you can see the build results the build
time the build queue time the local
startup time data transfer rate and
other things but at this point of time
you have stored your source code you
have created a bill there's one piece
still missing the security piece right
you still need to ensure the bill which
you just created does not have any
security vulnerabilities so cloud bill
comes with one Liberty scanner which
lets you scan your bills and ensure that
the bills you have are really secure but
for many organizations the process
doesn't even stop there what they need
is a way to have a policy set up as well
for example they want a policy to ensure
that none of the bills which have a
security vulnerability can ever be
deployed to do production and that's why
many of the organization would use
vulnerability scanner with another tool
which we release that next which is
called binary authorization using
vulnerability scanner and both through
binary authorization you can essentially
set up policies to decide what gets
deployed what doesn't get deployed right
now we are seeing only one ribbity
scanner and as you can see it has found
a founder validity so the next step
obviously is to resolve the
vulnerability so we resolve the
vulnerability by again clicking the red
button the only way to gets resolved and
you can see the scan being rerun every
year so till this time in the demo we
have created a bill we have scanned the
one already the next step obviously is
deploying the image now for deployment
piece over here we are using spinnaker
you must be familiar with spinnaker
since you work at Google so spinnaker is
an open source tool which Google
contributes to which Google is a core
contributor to with Netflix spinnaker
makes the process of creating deployment
pipelines across cloud on-premise
environments really easy and simple so
today for the for the demo we would be
deploying to let's say cloud
on the screen what you see is actually a
Bluegreen deployment taking place you
would see spinnaker going through
different stages of the pipeline and as
it goes through different stages of the
pipeline you would see the color
changing from blue to green for example
right now it's in the deploy a new
version to kubernetes image now it's in
the last image very where it's trying to
scale down previous pods and you would
see the color changing to green as soon
as the deployment gets completed right
in the looks like our app is deployed
you can see the app over here and
finally you get all the matrices for
building your app in a continuous
integration and continuous delivery man
any other questions for me giddy well I
know that this was a very simple and
efficient way to build an app but from
what I understand what makes this
helpful and useful is that it does allow
teams to be much more efficient and
productive is that correct absolutely
one of the biggest things which you
would see as a developer I would rather
focus on writing toward rather than
managing infrastructure especially
continuous integration and continuous
delivery pipeline I want to get wrap
fast feedback on my code I want to
ensure what I roll out to production is
of highest quality so all those things
are being built in through this pipeline
developers are able to focus on code
developers are able to get fast feedback
on code changes through continuous
integration and through things like
automated canary analysis which we have
built into spinnaker you ensure that
what the code which you're releasing to
production is of the highest quality
possible-- excellent well thank you so
much for sharing this demo with us and
what makes it helpful to our developers
enjoy the last few hours
[Music]